[Music]
so uh we're gonna be playing bad movie
live right now with you and you guys can
play along in chat and then after that
we'll be taking your chat directly to us
it's time to play bad movie
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so what are we playing today
uh uh quarter black gear or token now in
which movie lines what's the film the
film is
kill and kill again kill and kill again
all right what kind of movie is it's a
south african uh martial arts film oh my
gosh i feel like we are just walking up
the third rails at every moment here
south african really you picked a film
from the place that brought us apartheid
yeah how dare you it's the gods we're
already off twitter
does it start david carradine
no actually is it just nelson mandela in
a kung fu uniform
yes
what would you like me to do
and using tools around them it's just
prison bars
dr horatio kane
has been kidnapped
and is being forced to create an army of
martial artists okay okay yeah who will
help him take over the world obviously
you know yeah uh his daughter
candy cane oh
by the way the world has been almost
taken over several times in recent
history not once by throngs of martial
artists south african martial artists
vietnam the niche
guns yeah but that wasn't
i mean it's pretty impressive
it is impressive so candy cane uh
enlists the help of
steve chase our our hero right okay
horatio
okay
uh to rescue her father
all right okay so let's watch this and
then we have to guess the movie line
play the clip
everybody should have at least one
i have other weaknesses that come first
miss clean
please call me candy
sounds delicious
related to the missing nobel prize
winning chemist dr horatio king
he's my father
been missing two months i believe
not just missing kidnapped in fact
oh
very
sneaky a watch battery oh
somebody else must be interested
[Music]
in the piano
[Music]
has it been a ransom note or anything
you ruined my how does she respond say
ruin your drink they're not whiskey
people aren't interested in money they
want power sexy sexy power
b a ransom note what's that b or c or c
my father has been working several years
on a project to extract fuel from
potatoes hmm what do you think there
gerald i'll let you go what do you think
it is
because it's not a porn i'm going with
the potatoes thing the potatoes yeah if
it was pornography which it almost
sounds like that it could be a would be
closer to i'm not super familiar with
south african cinema well that's a good
point i'm not i'm not exactly then again
i was glad to not be familiar with
mexican cinema until roma worked its way
into my life oops oh and then it worked
its way right out you're watching
mosperos
uh what do you think
um i gotta say i gotta say b i mean i
think it it could be c ransom no but uh
i think b because she's kind of an idiot
yeah well i think that's true i mean if
she i'm candy cane
candy cane he said sounds to me i like a
good rain candy cane it washes
everything clean candy cane will you
touch me
i'm going to go see i don't know
i i'm honestly not i wasn't that was so
uh long i wasn't able to follow it so
i'm just going to say c
because i was earlier before the show
talking about dan aykroyd's potato vodka
so you know what i feel like it's
providential if not i'll cease believing
in god
why here we go
my father has been working for several
years
someone fetched my temple garments
and the stones i must consult them once
again
she really has a lot of information on
this she does yeah
she does all right let's watch this
potato fuel recipe we're willing to hide
in your piano until you give it to her
by the way
i think the piano keys didn't make his
ears hurt right before initially yeah
as a comedian this is also why like i
hate doing things like like i used to do
cpac for three four years i don't really
like doing these live speaking or
appearing on cable news because you know
as a comedian the more you can shorten
something the more you can distill it
the better it is when something is
overly complicated or they're trying to
connect a bunch of dots for the same
reason darren aronofsky is a horrible
film and i knew it long before the noah
rock men made their appearance
the shorter and the more dis the more
succinct you can make it uh the more
effective you can make it and then the
more impactful and the more storylines
you can necess you can sometimes include
or you can maybe explore the characters
a little bit more this idea sometimes
people go that's reductive sometimes
that's a very good thing if you're able
to take complex uh right complex notions
you're able to take complex concepts and
distill them in a way that someone who's
smart but isn't necessarily
a specialist in that area can understand
yeah that's great it's the same thing
with a film if you are writing something
like you're saying something about
potato and a battery and a drink and a
guy in a piano
where
i don't know where it's going
just shoot the broad and then go on to
something interesting
agreed yeah yeah movie over just put the
batteries over her eyes as part of the
traditional embalming ceremony because
no one we don't need any other candies
running around it's why so many movies
with almost no budget and a minimalistic
kind of attitude are so good sometimes
so i'm saying always but sometimes it's
deliberate right and then sometimes
those movies are made by joe swanberg
all right well that's true let's go to
the next clip so this next scene our
hero seeks out the guidance of the grand
sensei ah
the fly that's his name because i prefer
my grand sensei's to come from south
africa of course it's just jeff goldblum
yeah
uh well uh uh uh the left high kick uh
there it is
uh fly went into the
other machine yeah i'm gonna throw up on
you
[Laughter]
to knock your sensei
it's good when the extras are louder
than the people having dialogues
by the way if you translate it it's just
someone's drink order
who took all batteries from
turns around to reveal that it is a
black woman with a shaved head can't
escape jeff goldblum b
the room holds only a mirror our hero is
the fly
or c
the fly lights a candle with his foot
i can't believe that we just mentioned
jeff goldblum we had no clue it was
going to go the fly direction i'm
thinking it's going to go the fly
direction
what do you think that well it has to be
one of the flight drivers you got to
throw the choice please tell me it's
jeff goldblum letting a candle with his
foot that would be pretty impressive all
right what do you think there gerald
throw the things back up
things back up quarter black character
there we go all right
i'm going to say that it's the mirror
the hero is
the fly because he must be careful uh
mirror mirror uh
on the wall please tell me who who is
the fairest fly of all
is it me don't wait don't don't answer
that yet not until we have uh chardonnay
and uh get ourselves acquainted yes yeah
i'm gonna go lay shirtless
in a rock in a kid's movie
what do you think it is there uh uh dave
landau i want it to be a i might strike
out on this but i just want it to be a
oh well no there there it is
my issue is because of where it's filmed
they may not want that there right yeah
but apartheid yeah bring this back up
what are people saying they're in the
chat remember i'm going to say uh
you know what
i'm going to say i'm going to say c just
because it makes no sense overseas and i
just i'm not saying that uh the whole
country of south africa makes no sense
what i'm saying is the cultural
differences so it doesn't make sense to
me there you go yeah they could like
your reasoning they could be right and i
could be wrong i'd argue electrical
outlets but still we don't know you
don't like foot candles
oh you know
when in johannesburg yeah a foot candle
in the wind
diana's dead all right
all right here we go
there's a candle
oh what
oh
my god
that is not how i imagined this
this is gonna be even better if he has
hands
we're not going to see that better be
one of those trans amputees
identifies as being upper body limbless
yeah because being able to light a
candle with your foot wins all the
fights yeah i mean yeah i thought he was
going to kick it this is one of the
things that i will say this is one thing
that i will say about uh asian culture
sorry tokunawan and austin choi if you
look at asian martial arts yeah like the
real like the kung fu ones the ones that
are really popular especially in china
by the way they'll actually ban they'll
jail people who practice mma and beat up
old kung fu practitioners it's very much
into the mysticism and the look of
something yeah right that's what karate
kids spurred for dinner was like oh
waxing on waxing off meanwhile boxers
kickboxers judo practitioners which is
really japanese or luda like fighters
olympic wrestlers were learning how to
kick ass it's like well sure look you
can wax a car and go practice your
fighting lighting a candle with your
feet isn't going to do anything for you
unless you're in cirque du soleil and
you're going to be third string people
aren't waiting for the foot to be like
you see it once you've seen it a million
times yeah well that was the first time
i've seen it so now you're there you've
seen it a million times a million times
all right we have one more clip one more
clip one more final battery lines all
right final battle oh
final battle in south africa with asian
senseis this just seems like a breeding
ground for trouble
[Music]
yeah if i just stand still for eight
seconds
[Applause]
by the way this guy would be dead four
times oh yeah
just kill him just get ended
[Music]
just remember foot candles yes
the secret movie titty twister him with
his ring foot
my god oh man that move never worked no
of course not it's anti-leverage yeah
what is this
how long is this
it's coming up
i love how he lightly tapped
and cindy lauper's watching
[Laughter]
what does our hero do to in the fight
jumps onto the guy's back and breaks his
neck and screams b
doesn't flip in the air pauses for a
moment and kicks him once or c
does several cartwheels and immediately
yells which causes the guy to give i'm
hoping that ziggy stardust takes the
foot candle and shoves it down yes i do
too
uh i'm going with b does a flip in the
air pauses for a moment
and then kicks him once by the way this
is about as capable as bruce lee was and
people get really mad when you say it
it's just that bruce lee trained
hollywood uh producers yeah this is
exactly what it is they just take some
big looking muscular white guy or some
big muscular looking like japanese guy
uh or someone who's not chinese like
bruce lee could be kareem abdul-jabbar
the point is he is the guy who beats up
the bigger non-chinese guy yeah and it
looks just like that
and it's entirely fake stupid there he's
literally putting himself in a position
to get his ass kicked repeatedly well
he's already been like you said he's he
would be dead four times you know yeah
well listen this is the film come on
yeah i guess a film i guess that's
i don't really like their film so much
they make better shoes
all right uh which one do you think it
is
the one where he pauses in in the okay
what do you think you're going to be
here uh dave i'm gonna go breaks his
neck and screams let me see the options
again breaks his neck and screams and i
think
uh
you know what i've been going c this
whole time stick with it let me just
stick with it and go see because i think
that making the guy give up through his
so his stream would be better
yeah that's that's that's your war cry
it's like yo my little cry is when i
take balloon and go like this
you just see them on the hill horizon
uh i don't know i'm gonna go see
what's that young man doing oh there's
an iron floating in a tin can
[Applause]
that was technically a mix of only ones
i thought i had lost so i there was a in
there there was deck and screaming there
was all of the abilities oh you look you
lost i won i won the first two and then
were you gonna give me a half point for
three i lost the winner i'm still the
undefeated champion this has been bad
movie lines
i lost cause i left
[Music]
i swear that looks like you're dead like
just before the last scene where the guy
goes like that like that character right
before there anybody else i can't see it
i didn't see it it looks like pops
crowder i was too busy looking to
nicholas cage i know i do stare at that
i was one of the three people who saw it
in theaters my dad's dead thanks for
bringing that up oh you're talking about
neil breen
oh neil breen
i'm not saying it's like an exact
likeness i'm just saying it reminds me
of your dad it's your dad with a muppet
nose covered in blood
what a nice compliment let's talk about
your dad
you want to talk about his dad yeah no
absolutely no yeah i said my last
goodbye as a teenager yeah what do you
got for that you got nothing to say do
you i do he's got nothing tongue tied
tongue tied
but your dad did have it coming right
well yeah he served and got agent orange
listen
yeah i'm glad he's dead and i hope he
burned in hell what
what
that's a man who tells it like it is no
i love my daddy good man yeah now he's
trying to hide it he's like i'm gonna go
get cigarettes and i made up a story
i
we laugh so we don't cry yeah yeah it's
a joke he lost his dad i was locked out
of twitter okay alex has a question
uh my family are still very homosexual
even after all the info about the sexual
misconduct and all the grandma killing
they refuse to see any view other than
their far-left beliefs because they feel
if their views shift they will be seen
as ooh trump supporters
what can i do to get them to start
openly talking about these important
issues without causing fights has anyone
on the show had an issue like this with
their own family and how did they deal
with it lastly how do i get more of
these beautiful hand-edged mugs i don't
want anything else in my cabinet it's
the superior drinking vessel well the
good thing is if you join mud club you
always get one and you can enter that
discount 69 dollars annually no way to
do to do it and avoid a fight
so what i just say is find the
you said your whole this person said
their whole family right everyone in
their family pretty much their mom's
side of the family yeah so multiple
people so here's what you do there is no
way to do it without uh
getting into some kind of a fight we
know this when you have people there's a
difference between someone who's like ah
i don't know i think right now it's been
politicized i think he's done a pretty
good job that's where you can find some
common ground to change my mind and then
there are people if they refuse to see
any of the evidence with andrew cuomo at
this point there is no common ground to
be found you're going to find yourself
in a fight so what i advise you do is
since this is a whole side of your
family find the biggest most
intimidating member of said side of a
family and take him out first and then
everyone else prison rules okay yeah
learning to light a candle with your
foot
she got to kick somebody's ass or become
somebody's [ __ ] yeah
pretty much yeah yeah dave you went to
that second option too quickly a few
times i think i think yeah well he
understands it because also he did
prison time and crazy beats big every
time that's true ah he's just hanging
from nut sex like it was his job so
brady zimmerman has a question for dave
he says my last name is zimmerman but
i'm not latino
dave have you always been conservative
if not when did you realize that you
were and what was it that changed
um no i've actually not uh
always been conservative i don't even
know if i would necessarily say i'm
conservative i'm just put into that
category
uh now because anything that's not
extreme left or is logical brings us
here yeah right so
uh no i would say that most of my life
i've been extremely liberal but uh a
personal story my dad died from agent
orange in vietnam which we were talking
about yeah uh in poor taste yes in in
poor taste teasing my day i would have
left he was right very funny guy before
he'd he died from the va not caring
but speaks it like it is but yes when it
comes down to that that did cause that
uh which led to my mom's death and uh
when you when i break that down and i
look at the system that's in place i
feel that a lot of americans are
completely screwed over by the
government so i actually don't side
fully with any group and people might
say that might be a fake moderate but i
don't believe you until you do anything
right and so far i'm not seeing anybody
doing much
and that's just my own personal opinion
and once i start seeing a little bit
more compassion coming out of the
government other than just greed and
power hungry
yeah well i don't really have much of an
opportunity
especially the va because that's one of
the few legitimate roles of government
where if you're going to send out
soldiers to fight wars for this country
then you are beholden to taking care of
them that's one thing that should be
in the rare instance of bipartisanship
making sure that in other words before
we get to giving everyone health care as
a human right guess what that's an
earned right if someone served their
country yeah right it's one of them and
of course a beaking beacon of government
efficiency one of the worst health care
systems available in the united states
yeah oh absolutely and i as somebody who
has voted democrat many times and i did
vote for obama it's just the fact that i
well i'm sorry i had different opinions
then
but as i start getting when i start
seeing everything in the way that look i
firmly believe that the democrats
collapsed to this country to get a guy
out of office that might sound extreme
but if you look at what happened over
the last year it's what happened we use
scare tactics to screw over americans
cause mental illnesses that i've that
weren't there before destroy people's
jobs take away our pursuit of happiness
once you start doing that to people i
can no longer side with anything
nobody was really out for anybody but
themselves and i watched my dad suffer
until he was dead right
dave if this makes you feel any better
in this new bill i think we're sending
some money to pakistan for gender
studies yeah
that should be like a balm oh my god i'm
gonna go pee on my dad's ground the
remaining vietnam vets are coughing up
powdered tang yeah meanwhile they're
still trying to say that saw you know
certain tumors that people are well i
don't know if your parkinson's is from
agent orange right yeah it is it is uh
you know what though i think maybe you
you missed something where you said
because people are out for themselves
and that government has been screwing
people over that inherently makes you
right-wing and conservative because we
believe look it's we've talked about
this before inherently for either
ideology to work seeing the world
through a leftist point of view versus a
conservative point of view
constitutional point of view
as a conservative you have to believe
that people and this comes from this is
why most christians are conservatives
the idea of original that people are
inherently selfish people are inherently
flawed and bad yeah to believe that
liberalism will work you have to believe
that people are inherently good but only
the ones who vote for you they're all
inherently good therefore you want to
give them all that power in government
see conservatism says look people are
selfish people are easily corrupted
there's nothing more corrosive to the
human soul ironically than success and
power so we need to mitigate that and
that's why we don't want the government
to have
that much unmitigated power over our
lives we don't trust the human condition
and even good people can be corrupted we
see it all the time the left says look
they believe that because they're all
bad but we're all good and everything we
do is with an altruistic motive more
money please more money please yeah and
if they if the left really believed that
what they were selling you was worth it
they wouldn't have to take over every
news network every television show
force opinions and ideology onto you
that you don't believe whatsoever make
you know sitcoms involving a family
that's never existed do oreo commercials
with you know a family of it's like wait
there's a black you know an asian lady
but they got a white kid right you're
like what's that is that what you make
in the gillette commercials where dad's
teaching his son to shave his
yeah exactly that's true though
or the oreo commercials where that's a
real thing that is real it's real yeah
yeah yeah yeah that is a reflection i
never said father teaching
yeah the best a man can get
[Laughter]
not your son
the best day
not to be confused with by xenon and
yeah everything that you're talking
about um not only that you're talking
about these people they need to take
over control of all the media outlets
and now of course big tech outlets yes
education education have people who have
so little faith in their ideas that
they're going to lock us out
for a seven plus one cuomo pickup lines
that's how little they believe that
their ideas stand up to not only
scrutiny but mockery that's the brave
new world that we live in and guess what
some people say oh they should ease off
the pedal pull back probably not gonna
okay we got this one from alex question
crowder crew who would you want to run
and win in 2024 and why
is this alex jones
no is it alex jones
i want to see if you're one of the
lizard people
[Applause]
uh who would i like to run um i really
it's tough to always say i like ron
desantis quite a bit yeah uh gnome there
in uh in in one of the dakotas i always
forget which one yeah uh and listen if
if ted cruz were south
more
i mean i would still i would still
support ted cruz listen at the end of
the day i'm going to support a
republican if
they do what they said they would do
yeah if it's someone like a jeb bush or
someone probably even at this point like
a marco rubio or like a mitch mcconnell
type of course not if it's someone who i
think is is a little bit nutty like a
margin telegram of course not but anyone
within that spectrum someone who
actually does what that's the litmus
test did they do what they said they
would do when they achieved that office
ted cruz qualifies ron desantis
certainly qualifies
there's a whole bunch of people who you
know could be on that roster so i i
don't know and i try and avoid this
conversation because i don't want to
kneecap anyone at this point
since i don't throw my hat in the
political ring unless it's someone i
really really don't want because i see
them as a wolf and sheep
one issue alone taking out big tech
desantis he's the only person who's done
anything about it right now and and if
other people pick that mantle up and run
with it okay maybe i pick somebody else
but right now to santa you know i want
him because he doesn't want to do it
he's great he doesn't want to do it he
said i'm going to run for governor
because he can actually affect change in
florida and floridians love him yeah so
he looks like an action hero and he also
just doesn't have a rat with the media
he really doesn't he kind of has all the
qualities that we like from donald trump
yeah while being a little bit more
measured more polished too yeah yeah
absolutely um so yeah i
if you were to ask me right now i like
desantis because the biggest stories
have been coveted the biggest stories
have been you know the election issues
the biggest stories have been uh tech
big tech and he's been on the right side
of all of those very very boldly so
what's his what's his big tech thing oh
so he's creating a he's and i don't know
when it's going to be passed but a law
that you cannot ban that big tech cannot
ban any i believe it's politicians or
candidates from big tech platforms where
they face a hundred thousand dollar uh
per day fine
they could sue them yeah that's not a
lot of those big tech companies could
laugh at that they could but they can't
ban us at all yeah yeah but somebody has
to start doing something i agree right
and so he's actually fight there was
something else that he was doing we'll
have to we'll have to cover this next we
have to jump into it it was something
about your personal data as well oh yeah
yeah uh making uh ensuring your privacy
right so it was specifically more so
aimed at apple and amazon if i really
okay
but uh i know apple and facebook yeah uh
we actually have a segment in the works
on that but uh yeah so no a thousand
dollars a day and i i was 100 i had a
plan but then i realized i have to be
resident of florida so i was just going
to run for some unelected like some
actual elected position dog catcher you
know some county like oswego county if
that's a place and uh let's buy a car
then if they
they wouldn't be able to ban me but then
i floated i won't say that i floated the
idea to certain people who live in
mar-a-lago
[Applause]
but just seeing on twitter
i back because he's like on some city
council
now they're thinking about how that
impeachment failed he can run for 2024
yeah it could just just pick a county
where you got like 85 percent of the
vote in florida
and just just get it my father was a he
was constable which doesn't make any
sense he was basically a dog catcher in
a small community michigan he won by six
votes it was all his family
and he never even he never even took the
keys to the truck he just wanted to see
if he could win they never did it they
didn't even catch up we're just dogs
running a muck and now we have them all
over detroit
one more chat unless you think two more
but uh because we have to go uh i have
to to go tape some other sketches here
okay yeah we'll just we'll do one more
then all right megan um so brayden wants
to know let's see by the way you know i
know you're on the camouflage chat you
know i can still see you right
yes it doesn't always work okay brad
wants to know people tend to vote based
off of emotion democrat politicians are
naturally better at playing on emotion
conservative ideas are always better but
not necessarily emotional how do
republicans utilize emotion more to win
political races um well you're you're
largely correct in that you know it's
tough to compete against santa claus
right yeah just free internet free
school free how free drugs free health
screening
yeah free free money yeah um and i will
tell you
i can't tell everyone else how to do it
but this right here is an involuntary
emotional response laughter and that's
always why i focus that you have brian
county who's in comedy for how long have
you been 30 years 500 years yeah i mean
30 years yeah 500 years you take a nap
and grow a beard that's right i'm like
i'm like one of those arctic sharks
um yeah no i you know i started doing
stand up in my mid teens i was an actor
before that and this is the only thing
that i know
really how to do and i was told for many
many years at places like fox news and
conservative radio that it didn't work
the conservatives didn't like humor so
the problem is the market is created by
people from the top down saying no no
it's just got to be during obama it was
obama doomsday they asked me to write a
book about an obama doomsday thing and
i'd written
the the i had written the treatment for
change my mind yeah and they said no
um so
that's what i know how to do now if you
watch what we do with the actual change
in mind segments um it is logical it
uses a socratic method but it does i
think that you can appeal to people
emotionally if you at least present
uh the empathy behind it so like we just
talked about i understand i get really
pissed when people throw their trash in
texas it bothers me people throw their
trash out their window that really
bothers me um that being said that
doesn't mean that banning fracking is
going to help the environment but i
believe and i understand why people want
to have a cleaner earth to live on and
if you explain to people look i
understand where you're coming from you
want because give them the benefit of
the doubt people like the james
cameron's people like the uh the
falchies and the bidens of the world
they're what i call sort of the
manipulators these people who they don't
really care they just need to do it for
political gain so or the kathleen
kennedy's of the star wars world but the
people who believe it most of them
genuinely believe that well we have to
ban fracking because it's going to save
i don't know the penguins the manatees
whatever take your pick and if you
explain to them that it's actually worse
for the environment and you explain to
them look you need to understand that
right now we need energy or people will
die people need to keep themselves warm
this is a perfect opportunity to explain
to people right you've seen people
freeze yeah do you i don't want people
to die because they don't have energy
well neither do i we can't do it with
nothing but green energy so you have to
look at the energy available to us and
do you understand that oil being shipped
on on ships in barrels across the ocean
from saudi arabia is far more harmful
and energy inefficient for the
environment than fracking that we have
here and it's a place that violates
human rights and effectively has
indentured servitude if you tell them
that you listen you come to a different
conclusion because of your empathy only
you've used reason to reach it
a lot of people if they don't if they
don't actually change their own mind
they go
okay
at least you're not an apple there are a
lot of people out there who just think
with abortion you just want to control
women's bodies i have no interest in
controlling a woman's body in any other
aspect of her life only the other body
that is inside her body that has its own
beating heart in its own dna and then
even if those people say well you know
what my right to what i think and
convenience supersedes the scientific
definition of of life at that point they
go but i understand if you think it's a
life i understand why you line up that
way yeah and at least they don't see you
as a a robot so just sort of apply the
same empathy that they apply to their
conclusion and add reason and make sure
you do it you're constructing it in
front of them and even if you don't
change their mind right then they will
have a lot to think about and at least
you're probably the first conservative
not who they've met so that's a start
you know what that's really interesting
to say that because jonathan height
who's a psychiatrist did a lot of
psychologists did a lot of work on this
which is what you're saying is that if
somebody if you start out and you you're
talking to somebody who's on a different
spectrum than you are politically or
philosophically draw coming
drawing common ground first kind of like
respecting their point of view
or at least understanding where they're
coming from right is very important to
make any headway if you're talking to
somebody who's against guns and you go
you're a gun nut and the guy go no you
if you look at him and go you're up
because you don't like guys and he goes
you're a gun that the conversation's
over you what you can start with going
we both agree we don't want spree
shooters let's just agree that we we
want to solve that problem
and what's really interesting about what
you're saying is that height did some
really interesting things
liberals tend to have a narrower moral
palate according to him meaning
liberals usually are concerned but does
it cause harm and is it fair but
conservatives and most americans have a
broader moral palate it's not just about
whether it's fair or does it cause harm
it's also they also respect things like
sanctity
authority and loyalty loyalty to my
country that that's a big thing loyalty
to my group but for a liberal that
sounds like racism um uh sanctity sanct
the american flag uh sanctity of human
life and for a liberal that means well
you're trying to control a woman's body
now you're talking about a bunch of
religious mumbo-jumbo right um and and
authority for that matter my father the
head of the household or whatever well
that's the patriarchy so it all depends
on how you're looking at it but
americans and jonathan heights been
hired by liberal politicians to help
them connect with the with americans
who are in places like red states
because when you just when you're moral
palette when you're only talking about
whether it causes harm or fairness
americans are like hold on dude hold on
when you start tearing down statues yeah
and you start denigrating the founding
fathers that's sacred to me that's part
of my my tradition my heritage and being
an american well what's interesting too
from what you say is i think they have a
narrower moral palette but they they
sort of compensate for that by just the
terms that you just use are very broad
and undefined so they say oh fair well
fair isn't really something that you can
define because what you think is fair
maybe somebody else is when you say harm
right well i think that ending that
terminating the life of a nine-month-old
baby is harmful you don't have a single
democrat who's against it i'm not
talking about the morning after pill i'm
not talking about that let's even say
we're not talking about rape and it says
we're saying there's not a single member
currently at the head of the democratic
party
who has an opinion other than abortion
up until and including birth right now
eight months nine months right so they
say harm it will harm in the general
sense of the environment and the greater
good whereas i think with conservatives
we have a broader palette but we define
it we don't really care so much about
what's fair uh because you can't really
define it what's just well do we have
some kind of president yeah we have a
criminal justice system we have actual
um you know punishments that are
commensurate with the crime we actually
have something we can define we talk
about loyalty we can define loyalty
loyalty to what faith family freedom
right we actually set and that's why
it's so easy to say that conservatives
fall short uh of their standards because
they have them right when peop if if uh
for example there's that christian comic
because they found out and i'll leave
you with this i can't remember his name
chris something he was uh he got caught
sexting people
okay and he was like a guy with a
christian comedian was relatively
youtube stuff now here's the thing these
people weren't underage he did not
pressure into these people they were not
unwilling basically some women sent him
pictures and he sent some pictures in
response anyone else in hollywood that's
not a scandal right it's not a scandal
it's a guy engaging in a mutually
consensual
cyber relationship because he was fame
and he came out and said you know what i
actually uh i have not been living up to
my standards and i actually suffer from
a pornography addiction and sexual
addiction and i'm going to take some
time and everyone said
whereas those people have porn as their
favorite tabs on their browser but
they're like well at least i don't have
a standard well that's great but that's
nowhere to live that's just like you're
talking about a different way of looking
at human beings conservatives tend to
look at people as being essentially
flawed and who need restriction right
who need religion and family and and and
codes and things like that whereas
liberals tend to think that when you put
restrictions on people they can't be
themselves and so again it's how you
look at things well again it's but it's
also subjective they believe that you
can put restrictions on everyone but me
in other words i can put restrictions on
the business owner i can put
restrictions on the employee i can put
restrictions on the church i can put
restrictions on the person who started a
tracking business i can put restrictions
on elon musk i can put restrictions on
the car uh the car manufacturer who
makes suvs but i don't want any
restrictions for joe biden's authority
or anthony fauci because they think like
me and we should have complete and
unfettered power and i as a conservative
right-wing whatever you want to call me
i have a deep mistrust of human beings
and it also comes from a christian
worldview because we're all flawed we're
all fallen and so the safest thing that
we can do is avoid giving any one person
or any one group
unfettered amounts of power and by the
way that includes myself and anyone in
this room certainly brian cowan who's
going to be at the virginia beach funny
bone which day
friday saturday and sunday get your
tickets now just have pretty good days
i'm only going to have a big and hungry
podcast conspiracy social club on
patreon get it all you're not going to
do the friday show just thursday then
they send you on your way okay we see
you tomorrow hey if you like this video
it's actually clipped from the live show
every weekday monday through thursday at
10 a.m eastern you can just uh hit the
notification button subscribe and watch
it there and if you don't want this to
disappear from the big tech overlords uh
support us crowdershop.com look we got
the fight like hell shirt dave lando
he's got a baseball jersey check it out
right angel salazar yeah and then he uh
takes some uh can we say big big chief
are we allowed to say is that allowed
anyways he chews tobacco and throws up
on troikas